music's biggest night is almost here and
las vegas is the ultimate destination to
hold such a big event for the first time
the foot traffic that the grammys will
be bringing in is a big deal for small
business owners like the owner of the
secret menu aaron stewart owns the
secret menu offering a variety of drinks
traveling throughout the strip with his
beverage cart this weekend is a big deal
for him as he plans on staying put right
where the grammy's action will be for
someone who relies on foot traffic on
the strip he has been preparing for this
weekend ever since he knew the grammys
were making a debut in las vegas the
grammys coming to vegas is just an
amazing opportunity and the small
businesses don't take advantage of this
it's a missed opportunity because this
is the beginning of what seems to be the
future vegas getting these bigger venues
such as the grammys stewart joked that
if usher happened to stop by his car he
will definitely name a drink after him
stewart says he hopes big events
continue to give las vegas a chance to
see what this city has to offer
reporting from the las vegas strip
victoria saha live local now